Ivanka Trump once again faces questions
about whether she is personally
profiting from her White House role The
Associated Press reports the Chinese
government granted her company three new
trademarks on April 6 hours later she
dined with the Chinese president and her
father's mar-a-lago resort Jan Crawford
shows us how the president's daughter
has struggled to settle concerns over
potential conflicts of interest Jang
good morning good morning so Ivanka
Trump no longer runs her company but she
still is its owner and stands to profit
from those Chinese trademarks during the
Mara Largo dinner Ivanka Trump said
three seats away from President Xi
Jingping her daughter Arabella even
serenaded the Chinese leader and his
wife in Mandarin
there is no evidence that trademarks are
part of any quid pro quo but the
potential for a conflict of interest is
there according to george w bush's
former chief ethics lawyer because our
Constitution prohibits a United States
government office holder from accepting
presents from foreign governments
so these trademarks are gonna have to be
looked at very carefully to make sure
that they are routine trademarks
trademarks protect grants from copycats
and ripoffs CBS News has learned Ivanka
Trump's company filed at least eight
trademark applications in China last
year
shrimp is immensely popular in the
country and other businesses have been
trying to profit from her name says
company president Abigail clam the
statement Klem said it is our
responsibility to diligently protect our
trademark Trump's attorney added Ivanka
has had no involvement with trademark
applications submitted by the business I
have no involvement in its management
and its oversight in it Ivanka Trump
stepped down in January told CBS this
morning's Gayle King she left behind
safeguards I think by saying no deals
with foreign governments by saying that
any new deal that's being looked upon
has to run through an independent Ethics
Council so I create a tremendous
discipline that allows my team to
continue to do their jobs but do so in a
very restrained fashion still Trump's
company has reaped benefits from her
White House ties when Kelly and Conway
plug Trump's product line in February go
buy it today everybody write it online
traffic to Trump's website jumped 814
percent over its pre inauguration
average now that free commercial by
Conway also increased sales on another
website list as for those new trademarks
in China they reportedly will clear the
way for Ivanka Trump's jewelry bags spa
services all to be sold in a nation with
more than 1.3 billion people Gale all
right thank you very much Jan